안녕하세요, 제 이름은 데이비드 브라운이고 이 수업은 발음 수업입니다. 안녕하세요, 데이비드 선생님. 저는
잘 지내요, 감사합니다. 선생님은 어떠신가요? 저는 아주 잘 지내고 있습니다. 감사합니다. 감사합니다. 환영합니다.
감사합니다, 데이비드 선생님. 오늘 수업 준비되셨나요? 네. 좋습니다. 좋습니다. 그럼 우리가
선택하신 이 수업 내용을 연습해 볼 수 있겠네요. 우리는 이 짧은
i 소리와 그리고 이 긴 e 소리가 있습니다. 짧은 i 소리는 /ɪ/와 같고, 그리고
긴 e 소리는 /iː/와 같습니다, 그렇죠? 네. 이것은 우리가 숙달하는 것이 중요합니다. 왜냐하면
영어 원어민에게 혼란을 야기할 수 있고, 이것은 정말로
흔하게 잘못 발음되는 쌍이기 때문입니다. 그래서 여기 몇 가지 예시가 있습니다. 재미있는
예시들이죠. fill과 feel, sit과 seat, chip과
cheap이 있습니다. 이것은 bit입니다. 이것은 beat, beat, ship이고 이것은 sheep입니다. 이것은
lid이고 이것은 lead입니다. 네. 그래서 우리는 /ɪ/ 소리와
/iː/ 소리, /ɪ/ 소리와 /iː/ 소리의 차이를 알아야 합니다. 네.
짧은 /ɪ/ 대 /iː/ 소리입니다. 이것이 오늘 수업에서 연습할 내용입니다. 두 가지
다른 소리죠. 예를 들어, 이것은 무엇일까요? 이것은 ship*, ship, 아주 좋습니다. 그리고 이것은,
이것들은 sheep입니다. 이것들은 sheep이죠, 그렇죠? 규칙 복수 명사입니다. 그래서 우리는
약간 까다로울 수 있지만 명확한 발음을 위해 매우, 매우 중요한 두 가지 영어 소리를
살펴보고 있습니다. 우리는 이해하고 이해받기를 원하며 이것은 우리의
이해력에 영향을 미칠 수 있습니다. 그래서 단어의 의미를 바꿀 수 있죠. 우리는 이것,
ship이 있고, 이것, cheap이 있습니다. 이것은 단지 하나의 예시일 뿐입니다. 그래서 오늘 우리는
여기 두 가지 목표가 있습니다. 이 목표들을 들어보셨으면 합니다. 오늘 여러분은
/ɪ/와 /iː/의 차이를 듣는 법을 배우고, /ɪ/와 /iː/를 더 명확하게 말하는 법을 배울 것입니다. 이것을
시도해 봅시다. 저를 따라 반복해주시겠어요? /ɪ/. 이제, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/. 멋지네요. 그래서 우리는 연습을 위한 작은
활동이 여기 있습니다. 제가 막대기 같은 것과 블록 같은 것이
필요하다고 말씀드렸죠. 그래서 저는 색연필과 제 딸의 블록 중 하나를 가지고 있습니다. 무언가
가지고 계신가요? 네, 네, 저도 뭔가 있어요. 네, 네, 이런 거요. 좋습니다, 그럼
/ɪ/ 소리가 있고 그것이 블록을 두드리는 것과 같다고 상상해봅시다. 네, 그렇죠? 그럼 /ɪ/ 하면서
블록을 두드려보세요, /ɪ/라고 말해보세요. 이제 더 긴 /iː/ 소리가 있습니다. 여러분이 연필을 가지고
무언가에 대고 끄는 것을 상상할 수 있습니다, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/. 좋습니다, /iː/. 네, 그럼
다시 들어보세요, /ɪ/, /ɪ/ /iː/, /iː/. 턱이 변하는 것을 주목하세요. 혀가 입안에서
하나의 소리보다 다른 소리에서 더 높은 위치에 있습니다. 이것은 모두 입안에서의 혀의 위치에
관한 것입니다, /iː/ 소리 대 /ɪ/ 소리, /ɪ/는 조금 더 편안합니다. 네. 차이가
들리시나요? 네. 네, 훌륭합니다. 그래서 짧은 i, /ɪ/ 소리는 /iː/ 소리와
조금 다릅니다. /iː/는 더 그렇고, 혀가 더 위로 올라간 상태에서 /iː/입니다. 우리는
턱이 더 아래로 내려간 상태에서 /ɪ/ 소리가 납니다, /iː/, 제 입 모양 보이시죠, /iː/, 그렇죠? 네, 이제
/ɛ/라고 말하고 싶지 않으실 겁니다. 그리고 이것은, 우리는 lead (금속)처럼 /ɛ/ 소리가 있고, lid처럼 /ɪ/ 소리가
있고, 그리고 lead (이끌다)처럼 /iː/ 소리가 있습니다. 그리고 이 모든 것은 입안에서의 혀의 위치에
따라 다릅니다. 우리는 /ɛ/, /ɪ/, 그리고 /iː/가 있습니다. 저를 따라 반복하세요, /ɛ/, /ɪ/, /iː/   /ɛ/, /ɪ/, /iː/
/iː/. 아주 좋습니다. 네, 그래서 혀나 턱의 위치에 따라 이 소리들에는
몇 가지 차이점이 있습니다. 그래서 입을 스페인어의 /i/보다 조금 더 벌려야 합니다.
입술은 편안하게, 웃는 모양도 아니고 꽉 다문 모양도 아닙니다. 그래서 /ɪ/의 경우, 이것은
조금 더 그렇고, 그냥 /ɪ/, /ɪ/입니다, 그렇죠? /ɛ/가 아니고요. 혀는 약간 높고, 약간
앞쪽에 있고, 혀를 약간 편안하게 해야 합니다. 그리고 이것은 빠르고, 짧은
빠른 소리입니다, 마치 블록을 가볍게 두드리는 소리처럼요, 그렇죠? 네. 느껴보세요, 편안하게. 그럼
이 소리를 직접 내보세요. 음소거하셔도 됩니다. 이 소리를 다시 한번 직접 내보세요.
한번 들어볼게요. 네, /ɪ/, /iː/ 그리고 /ɪ/, 그리고 /iː/, 아주 좋습니다. 훌륭해요. 네. 좋습니다.
그리고 이 연습을 조금만 해도 큰 차이를 만들 수 있습니다. 자 이제 저에게
보여주세요... 거울을 사용하셔도 되고 카메라도 사용하셔도 됩니다. 카메라 사용이 너무 부끄러우시다면,
거울을 사용하셔도 괜찮습니다. 그럼 카메라로 자신의 입 모양을 보세요.
네. 이렇게요. /ɪ/, /ɪ/, /ɪ/, /ɪ/, /ɛ/가 아니라 /ɪ/... /ɪ/ , 그리고 /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, 완벽합니다.
네, 그래서 입술이 고무줄처럼 넓게 벌어진 입 모양이 있습니다,
/iː/ 소리가 나는 곳이죠, 그리고 혀는 높고 앞쪽에 있으며, 약간의 긴장을 느낄 수 있습니다. 그래서
우리는, 이것, 즉 /iː/ 소리, 이것은 /ɪt/이고, 이것은 /iːt/입니다, 그렇죠? 맞아요.
이것은 길고, 늘어지는 소리입니다, 마치 무언가를 당기는 것처럼요. 그래서 /iː/ 소리를 낼 때
입꼬리에 고무줄을 당기는 것처럼 상상할 수 있습니다.
여기 이미지에서 이것을 볼 수 있습니다. 여기 /ɪ/ 소리가 있는데, 이것은 중앙
앞쪽에 있습니다. 턱은 중간에서 닫힌 상태이고, 편안합니다. 그리고 /iː/ 소리는 더 벌어져
있습니다. 조금 더 닫혀 있고, 혀는 약간 더 위로 올라가 있습니다.
잘하셨어요. 네, 그럼 이것들 중 일부를 연습해봅시다. 여기 우리를 위한 활동이 있습니다. 여러분은
블록과 연필이나 펜, 또는 뭐든지, 막대기를 가지고 계시죠. 네. 그럼 여러분이, 제가 말할 때,
또는, 그리고 여러분이 이 짧은 /ɪ/ 소리가 들어간 단어를 말할 때, 블록을 두드리시기 바랍니다.
네. 그리고 긴 /iː/ 소리가 날 때는, 막대기를 미끄러뜨리시기 바랍니다. 준비되셨나요?
준비됐습니다. 네. 그럼 ship. 반복하세요, ship, ship.
네. Ship. Ship. Get. Bed. Bed. Beats. Beats. Ship. Ship. 그리고 ship.
Sheep. 좋습니다. Sit. 좋습니다. Fill. Feel. Feel. 좋습니다. 네. 이 /ɪ/ 소리로 조금 더 연습할 수 있습니다.
/ɪ/ 소리요.